pora bachelor contestant Erica Rose is  expecting her first child and sharing  the details with et the reality star  took to Instagram to confirm the news  that she and her boyfriend Galen Gentry  are expecting she told me t-that the  couple found out when they took a  pregnancy test two weeks ago saying  quote when I found out we were pregnant  he promised to be the best husband to me  and the best father to our baby it was a  really special moment  - then went to celebrate the news at  pink taco  Erica even shared a photo that day  drinking a non-alcoholic margarita with  the caption celebrating good news Erica  says the baby is due in late September  and they don't know the gender yet but  Erica says quote I think it will be a  girl and luckily we aren't having twins  Erica competed on season 9 of The  Bachelor and went on to compete on  bachelor pad